peut-être un début de désescalade c'est
ce que le retrait des troupes russes aux
abords de l'ukraine laissent entendre
alors que plusieurs pays craignait une
invasion de l'est du pays plus de dix
mille soldats de l'armée de vladimir
poutine sont de retour dans leurs bases
après un mois d'exercices militaires
près de la frontière
une partie seulement des dizaines de
milliers d'hommes massés dans la zone
par moscou une manoeuvre en accord avec
les récentes déclarations du président
poutine lui dit vouloir que les
négociations à genève autour du conflit
dans la région ukrainienne du dombass
aboutisse la russie soutient les
séparatistes de cette région de l'est de
l'ukraine eux affrontent les forces
gouvernementales du pays dans un conflit
qui dure depuis 2014 et qui a fait plus
de 14 mille morts les estimations du
nombre de soldats russes à la frontière
ukrainienne varie entre 60000 et 90
mille hommes moscou réclame de son côté
à l'union européenne et aux états unis
l'assurance que l'ukraine ne rentre pas
dans l'otan conditions russes pour que
davantage de soldats quittent la zone
frontalière